on change d'actualité mon reste attrape
le week-end dernier était organisé le
mondial d'improvisation juniors quatre
équipes participer à l'événement et pour
cette troisième édition ce sont les
jeunes français qui se sont imposés en
finale face au québécois de justesse 7
assists écoutez à ce propos le
responsable du secteur improvisation de
déclic à théâtre la compagnie qui a
organisé ce mondial et ça s'est super
bien passé franchement c'était trop cool
là il ya eu des grands moments des
grands moments de fête des grands
moments de plaisir de partage de de fun
du jeu il ya eu de l'impro enfin je sais
pas comment je peux le définir mais si
je dois essayer de résumer ce qui s'est
passé ça a été vraiment un vrai
carrefour de de la culture de
l'improvisation théâtrale en fête et du
match d'improvisation parce que chacun
est venu avec un petit peu ses manières
de faire et où ils sont adaptés à ce
qu'on nous propose la trappe